hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for tonight again
for another guy this time going to be on
the new missile launcher that just got
released into Ford now I'm having tons
of fun of this weapon this has to be one
of my favorite weapons that just
released with the game so I have a few
tips to talk about some things and well
basically what we're gonna be doing
we're gonna be going over the damage and
the stats planned to move on to when and
when not to use the weapon as well as
some other general quick tidbits of
information and talk about my overall
thoughts and if this thing is viable
against its competition
this being the grenade launcher in the
RPG so let's get started so to start
this is an epic and legendary tier gun
meaning it's purple and gold the purple
does 105 damage with the gold doing 110
it does a thousand damage to the
environment with just crazy damage
numbers and the missile is guided
meaning you control it once you shoot it
but your character is stuck in one place
and can't move unless you detach it I
believe it's with the left mouse click
on PC I believe that's right trigger on
Xbox I don't know what it is for ps4 but
it's basically you're shooting button
basically it detaches it but once you
detach it you can't control the
direction until you reattach yourself
with it of course and then it just goes
straight and the missile launcher also
moves slightly slower than a normal
rocket launcher and can be only found in
chests in supply drops but just because
it's slow doesn't mean you can't travel
far and the clips my friends and I were
screwing around with this since we just
got it to drop for the first time and I
shot a rocket from the hills near
haunted all the way to Pleasant which is
some pretty decent far range the timer
on the thing is about 18 I believe it's
15 to 18 seconds of time before it
shorts out and you can't use it anymore
as for when it's useful it's very useful
in squads and duo's as to post a solo in
my opinion using this weapon leaves you
open to base rushers and you can be
killed while using it and no one is
watching your back in solo it's also
very nice for long distance fights or
when the opponent is distracted if two
people are fighting go for one of them
since they'll be more occupied on the
person in front of them and then not you
about 20 miles away with the missile
launcher you can also use the missile
launcher if you want to to get a
bird's-eye view let's say you're
chilling up on the top of a hill and you
can't see below you basically just look
up in the air and you're gonna get a
bird's-eye view of the people around you
and all their bases in the clip we were
fighting a team atop a hill and when I
went to missile launched the team at the
bottom I spotted another team that was
rushing us which if I didn't discover
them could have gotten us killed so this
weapon is very good for surveillance now
now not only is it good for kill
it's also good for rocket riding rocket
riding using an RPG used to get you
killed a lot since if you left your very
left open in the middle of nowhere
especially if the enemies are directly
ahead of you
now you can swerve and maneuver all you
want to a base it's like another form of
base rushing but a lot slower if you
transport your team and yourself if you
detach the rocket before it hits and
base rush an opposing squad on top of
the transporting the team you can also
blow up their base simultaneously while
transporting your team since obviously a
rocket launcher so basically you're
multitasking with the weapon if you're
in a teamfight like in the clip I had my
buddies distract the people in front of
us while I blasted them to bits from the
back this is so much fun and I can't
stress it enough how fun this weapon was
to use the first time we got it for one
not to use the weapon though it
definitely has to be close range or solo
play especially if you're at the end of
the game well you can use the launcher
in the endgame and that's completely
fine keep in mind that you may not be
the only one with the missile launcher
and since you're controlling it it can
leave you exposed you can get flanked
and not even know about it
it still works if you want to get a
bird's-eye view of opposing enemies but
just be careful since you're obviously
vulnerable to attacks and if it's the
end game there's not going to be lots of
noise since people are going to be
hiding in their bases and then they're
going to see the RPG and know exactly
where their next targets going to be
it's definitely more beneficial to use a
rocket launcher in a close-range fight
since it's faster than the missile
launcher and you know have to be locked
in the animation for it so if you happen
to be close range or in a building use
the regular rocket launcher instead as
opposed to the missile launcher I'm not
saying that if you're in solos don't
ever use the missile launcher you can
use it as just as much as you want you
just have to be a lot more cautious of
your surroundings when you do so one
other quick thing that I noticed is
during when I was playing with the
missile launcher is that it's also very
nice to pair with if you have a sniper
rifle the semi-automatic or the bolt it
doesn't really matter all you need to
know about is the scope since obviously
the sniper has the longest scope and you
can see very far you can spot people
from a mile away and then use your
missile launcher to go actually do the
damage and if you don't want to use the
sniper I found out that that was pretty
useful since obviously like I said the
sniper has lots of range so you could
basically see the whole map roughly or
that area that you're in depending on
how big the circle is you can see
everybody around you and spot out
everyone for my overall thoughts though
this weapon does a lot of damage which
is obvious since it is a rocket launcher
but my only problem is that it can be a
little bit overpowered especially when
you're on the receiving end in someone
rushing you while the other guy hangs
and shoots missiles from afar so that is
a bit overpowered but it does have its
drawbacks that being that you have to be
stationary when controlling it which
could cause people to flank you or rush
you without you knowing and the fact
that there's a smoke trail that travels
behind it so you know where the initial
rocket was fired making easier for you
to find that person shooting it for
comparing in terms of other weapons
similar to it comparing the to the
grenade launcher this is a way better
choice it could shoot farther and you
can obviously guide the rocket or you
want to go as opposed to the grenade
launcher where it it goes far but not as
far as the missile launcher and it just
does a lot more damage compared to the
regular rocket launcher it depends on
the situation if you're in a close
engagement with the team or an enemy use
a rocket launcher if you're in squads or
duo's and have the team rush up and
distract them while you flank around
with the missile launcher that's fine
too or you can sit in a comfy base with
your buddies get a cozy campfire down
and get a bird's-eye view of the people
or pick off people from the comfort of
your own base either situation is fine
as well but that is going to be the end
of the video like I said just the cue a
few quick tips to definitely nail into
it's very good in squads especially if
you want to be that dude that hangs back
sits in your own mini base and just
shoots from afar while they're getting
distracted because obviously they have
to focus on the rocket launcher and the
teammates rushing though it's definitely
very useful in a squads and duos
environment and then just be wary if you
are using it the people around you just
in case you happen to get rushed up on
while you're using it because then
you're completely vulnerable to
everything they do but that's going to
be the end of the video today guys if
you have any other questions definitely
leave it in the comments below I'll try
to answer all of them if need be and if
you have any other tips that I didn't
put in the video that you think is worth
noting about the specific weapon also
putting that in the comments below for
other people to know so we can all get
caught up on the info subscribe if
you're new I'm covering a lot more of
these guides on for tonight especially
with the new weapons coming up that seem
to be every single week we're getting
new stuff and if there's a new type of
landing spot like a point of interest
I'm going to be covering that and
specific you know for example lucky
landing if anything else new similar to
that comes out I'll be covering guides
on those as well as other tips to make
everybody a better player whether that
be building or anything on the offense
defense all the type of stuff I'm gonna
I have guides coming out for some of
that stuff in the future my two most
recent videos are gonna be on screen if
you guys do want to check that out and
with that guys hope you have a great
rest of your day and peace out